AMERICAN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AS DEMOCRATS TIPTOE THROUGH THE
MINEFIELD OF CONTROVERSY BROUGHT
ON BY THEIR MOST OUTSPOKEN NEW
STARS, WE ARE REMINDED AGAIN OF
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS TRUMP
WON AND IS STILL LOOKING PRETTY
GOOD FOR 2020.
UNABASHED AND AMERICANISM.
>> AMERICA IS THE GREATEST
FIGHTING FORCE FOR PEACE,
JUSTICE AND FREEDOM.
IN THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR AMERICA.
WE ARE GOING TO STAND UP FOR
AMERICA.
NO MORE APOLOGIES.
>> Laura: NO MORE APOLOGIES,
NO MORE GROVELING, NO MORE SELF
LARGE LETTING OURSELVES ON THE
WORLD STAGE AS A CERTAIN
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION HAD
DONE.
>> IN AMERICA, THERE IS A
FAILURE TO APPRECIATE EUROPE'S
LEADING ROLE IN THE WORLD.
INSTEAD OF CELEBRATING YOUR
DYNAMIC UNION AND SEEKING TO
PARTNER WITH YOU TO MEET COMMON
CHALLENGES, THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WHERE AMERICANS SHOWED
ARROGANCE AND BEEN DISMISSIVE,
EVEN DERISIVE.
>> Laura: I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT APOLOGIES ARROGANT BUT
TRUMP IS DIFFERENT.
HE GOES OVER TO EUROPE AND HE
SAYS HEY, WE VALUE OUR ALLIANCE.
WE LOVE YOU GUYS, BUT IT'S TIME
FOR NATO MEMBERS TO STOP FREE
WRITING ON THE AMERICAN TAXPAYE
TAXPAYER.
>> I HAVE BEEN VERY, VERY
DIRECT.
NATO MEMBERS MUST FINALLY
CONTRIBUTE THEIR FAIR SHARE AND
MEET THEIR FINANCIAL OBLIGATION
OBLIGATIONS.
BUT 23 OF THE 28 MEMBER NATIONS
ARE STILL NOT PAYING WHAT THEY
SHOULD BE PAYING.
THIS IS NOT FAIR TO THE PEOPLE
AND TAXPAYERS OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: IMAGINE THAT.
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT IN EUROPE
STANDING UP FOR YOU, LOOKING OUT
FOR YOUR HARD-EARNED MONEY.
OF COURSE THE FOREIGN POLICY
ELITES BACK HOME, THEY SHUDDERED
AND THEY FUMED, SPUTTERED UPON
HEARING ALL OF THIS.
PREFERRING OF COURSE THIS
APPROACH.
>> THE UNITED STATES WILL BE
WILLING TO ACKNOWLEDGE PAST
ERRORS WHERE THOSE ERRORS HAVE
BEEN MADE.
THE UNITED STATES IS STILL
WORKING THROUGH SOME OF OUR OWN
DARKER PERIODS IN OUR HISTORY.
EACH COUNTRY MUST WORK THROUGH
ITS PAST, AND RECKONING WITH THE
PAST CAN HELP US HE'S A BETTER
FUTURE.
>> Laura: SEIZING A BETTER
FUTURE IS EXACTLY WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEGUN TO DO
FOR AMERICA.
BUT NOT BY MARINATING IN GUILT
OVER PAST WRONGS IN PUBLIC BUT
BY GROWING THE ECONOMY, REAL
HELP.
THE OBAMA CREW SAID HE COULDN'T
DO IT, BUT WITH A CRACK TEAM OF
DEDICATED PROS, TRUMP
RENEGOTIATED OLD TRADE DEALS TO
MAKE THEM MORE PRO-AMERICAN
WORKER.
AND HE'S HOLDING TRADE TEACHERS
LIKE CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
IT'S ABOUT TIME.
CAN YOU IMAGINE KAMALA HARRIS,
CORY BOOKER OR PETE BUTTIGIEG
SPEAKING AS TRIUMPHANTLY, AS
UNAPOLOGETICALLY ABOUT AMERICAN
DOMINANCE IN MANUFACTURING AS
TRUMP?
>> TODAY, JOBS ARE COMING BACK
AND POURING BACK FRANKLY LIKE
NEVER BEFORE.
COMPANIES ARE COMING BACK INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
THEY WANT THE ACTION.
PRODUCTION IS RAMPING UP IN THE
BIGGEST WAY.
THE AWESOME M1 ABRAMS TANK IS
ONCE AGAIN THUNDERING DOWN THE
ASSEMBLY LINE.
>> Laura: TRUMP IS ALSO
UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT'S DUTY TO ENFORCE OUR
BORDERS.
AND ALSO TO TAILOR IMMIGRATION
TO AMERICA'S NEEDS AND VALUES.
BY CONTRAST, THE DEMOCRATS
RECOILED FROM SUCH TERMS AS
AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY, AND THEY
PUSH INSTEAD FOR ABOLISHING
I.C.E. AND EVEN ABOLISHING THE
CLASSIFICATION OF ILLEGALS AS
ILLEGALS.
>> WE ARE STANDING ON NATIVE
LAND AND LATINO PEOPLE ARE
DESCENDANTS OF NATIVE PEOPLE.
WE CANNOT BE TOLD AND
CRIMINALIZED SIMPLY FOR OUR
IDENTITY OR OUR STATUS.
GREAT NECK.
>> Laura: PERIOD.
AGAIN, THEY FEEL ANGRY ABOUT
AMERICA'S PAST AND PRESENT.
AMERICA ACTING IN AMERICA'S
INTEREST, NO, YOU CAN DO THAT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS PARTICULARLY
INCENSED LAST WEEK WHEN FOOTAGE
CIRCULATED A FRESHMAN
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR
REFERRING TO REFERRING TO 9/11
AS AN OCCASION WHERE SOME PEOPLE
DID SOMETHING.
SO HE RETWEETED OMAR'S VIDEO AND
THEN HE INCLUDED CLIPS OF THE
PLANES GOING TO THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER TOWERS.
THE LEFT, THEY WEREN'T UPSET
ABOUT OMAR'S ORIGINAL COMMENTS.
THEY ARE MAD AT TRUMP, CLAIMING
HE IS THE PROBLEM ENDANGERING
THIS WOMAN'S LIFE.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING TO
INCITE VIOLENCE AND TO DIVIDE
US.
>> SHE DOES NOT DESERVE THE KIND
OF VICIOUS, HATE FILLED ATTACKS
THAT SHE'S EXPERIENCING, THREATS
ON HER LIFE.
>> THIS IS AN INCITEMENT TO
VIOLENCE.
AGAINST CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR,
AGAINST OUR FELLOW AMERICANS WHO
HAPPEN TO BE MUSLIM.
>> Laura: I AM JUST GLAD
SOMEONE FOUND BETO.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM IN A WHILE.
IN A LOCAL INTERVIEW IN
MINNESOTA YESTERDAY, TRUMP WAS
CHARACTERISTICALLY UNAPOLOGETIC
WHEN ASKED IF HE HAD SECOND
THOUGHTS ABOUT CRITICIZING OMAR.
THE PRESIDENT REPLIED NO, NOT AT
ALL.
WELL, SHE'S BEEN VERY
DISRESPECTFUL TO THIS COUNTRY.
SHE'S BEEN VERY DISRESPECTFUL
FRANKLY TO ISRAEL.
SHE HAS SOMEONE THAT DOESN'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND I THINK LIFE.
REAL LIFE.
WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
SHE'S GOT AWAY ABOUT HER THAT'S
VERY, VERY BAD I THINK FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
I THINK SHE'S EXTREMELY
UNPATRIOTIC AND EXTREMELY
DISRESPECTFUL TO OUR COUNTRY.
WELL, I THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS
GREW THAT.
LIKE OBAMA BEFORE HER, OMAR
REFLECTIVELY APOLOGIZES EVEN IN
TONE RIDICULING AMERICA FOR
BEING WORRIED ABOUT AL QAEDA.
>> WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE, I TOOK
A TERRORISM CLASS.
EVERY TIME THE PROFESSOR SAYS
AL QAEDA, HE SORT OF GOES LIKE,
HIS SHOULDERS WENT UP.
AL QAEDA.
YOU DON'T SAY AMERICA WITHOUT
INTENSITY.
YOU DON'T SAY ENGLAND WITHOUT
YOU DON'T SAY THE ARMY WITH AN
INTENSITY.
>> Laura: YES, BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY RECOIL AT EVIL.
AMERICA AND BRITAIN, WE DON'T
BELIEVE ARE EVIL, CONGRESSWOMAN.
SO WE BRISTLE AT -- SOMETHING IS
OFF ABOUT THAT.
WE BRISTLE ABOUT IT.
GOT TO BE CLEAR HERE.
SHE'S NOT ALONE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS BECOMING
INFECTED WITH THIS SELF-LOATHING
QUALITY, MEANING MORE OF ITS
MEMBERS TODAY FEEL GUILTY ABOUT
AMERICA'S PAST AND THEY WANT TO
TURN THAT GUILT INTO THE
ULTIMATE EXPIATION FOR OUR SINS,
THE SINS OF COLONIALISM, RACISM,
MISOGYNY, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
KEEP GOING.
AND THEY FEEL JUSTIFIED IN
TEARING DOWN HISTORY AND
ATTACKING RELIGIOUS SYMBOLS WITH
DEEP HISTORICAL ROOTS, AND EVEN
REFUSING TO PARTICIPATE IN
PATRIOTIC DISPLAYS.
2020 IS SHAPING UP TO BE A
SHOWDOWN BETWEEN MORE
TRADITIONAL AMERICA AND THIS NEW
KIND OF TWISTED VISION OF
AMERICA.
NO MATTER WHO THE DEMOCRATIC
ANEMONE IS, THIS IS THE
IDEOLOGICAL STRUGGLE BEFORE US.
IT'S HARD RIGHT NOW TO IMAGINE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD NOT
AGAIN EMBRACE THE TRUE AUDACITY,
THE UNAPOLOGETIC NATURE OF
TRUMP.
HIS UNWILLINGNESS TO BOW DOWN TO
THE MEDIA AND POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS OF THE MOMENT AND
HIS DETERMINATION TO PROTECT THE
HONOR AND THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY.
HIS HABIT OF STANDING UP TO THE
POLITICAL ELITE AND REFUSING TO
BACK DOWN.
THERE ARE WORDS FOR THIS
APPROACH.